Transcriber: Ataa Al Ayoubi
المدقّق: Yahya Mansour
[أحمد جمل]
مساء الخير جميعاً أو صباح الخير.
مرحباً!
أود أن أشارككم،
تجربتي في مجال الحفاظ على التراث الثقافي،
مثل ما ذكر صديقنا.
وكما ذكر أيضاً أنا تخرجت
في الهندسة المدنية من جامعة بير زيت،
وخلال مسيرتي التعليمية لم أشعر
بالفضول تجاه علوم هذا المجال،
كالباطون المسلح والحديد والأحمال.
كنت دائم الفضول في مجال المباني القديمة.
لم أشعر أن هنالك تركيز جدي في المقررات
على هذا المجال الهندسي المهم والتاريخي،
من ناحية التراث المعماري.
كنت محظوظاً في تلك الفترة، منذ 6 سنوات،
بمشاركتي في مشروع ترميم
في “دير الصلاحية” عند “باب الأسباط“.
لا أعلم إن كنتم تعرفون “دير الصلاحية“.
هو موقع تاريخي مميز جداً
من ناحية طبقاته التاريخية.
وفي تلك الفترة والفرصة التي أتشرف بها،
وفي إحدى الأيام وأنا عائد إلى البيت
سيراً على الأقدام،
شاهدت موقفاً ترك أثراً في حياتي المهنية.
وأنا أتمشى في الطريق كان هناك شاب،
عمره 16 أو 18 سنة، جالس يشرب العصير
وتوجد خلفه أرض خالية
ومنخفضة قليلًا عن مستوى الشارع
وأمامه حاوية نفايات
ووقعت عيناي عليه وهو يشرب العصير ثم
ينهيه ويرمي زجاجة العصير إلى الخلف
وبشكل لا إرادي توقفت وعاتبته قائلاً :
“لماذا!” “الحاوية أمامك!”
فرد عليّ بعفوية بكلمتين فقط.
قال لي :“نحن عرب“.
عندها عجزت عن الكلام،
عقد لساني، وطأطأت رأسي،
وأكملت طريقي إلى البيت.
ولكن لم أستطع أن استوعب ما حصل.
ماذا يقصد بقوله “عرب“؟
كوني شخص مهتم بالتراث
التاريخي والمعماري والحضاري لبلادنا
أنا متأكد ومدرك أننا العرب
في فترة من التاريخ كنا نصدر الحضارة
والأخلاق والعلوم للعالم.
وأنت تقول لي اليوم “نحن عرب” [استنكار]
مع الأسف هذا هو واقعنا اليوم.
ولكن يمكننا تغييره إن شاء الله.
عندما أفكر بالتراث الثقافي لبلادنا
وجماله
والعناصر المعمارية الجميلة جداً
من بينها الأقسام والأقواس والقبب
بكل تفاصيلها.
مقابل المنتوج المعماري الذي نبنيه اليوم.
الذي هو مجرد مباني إسمنتية مربعة،
بدون أية مقومات، أو طاقة
يمكن الشعور بها في هذه الأماكن.
ولا تحوي على أية روح
من الحياة الإجتماعية التي كانت في تاريخنا.
هذا الموقع في قرية “كور“، التي تتميز
بموقعها الاستراتيجي في سفوح الجبال،
وبقصورها وقلاعها التاريخية،
التي تحمل روحاً - كما كنت أقول -
في طيات عناصرها.
ولكنني صدمت للأسف بمعرفة أن
أصحاب هذه القلاع التاريخية،
قد تركوها وأهملوها
ليسكنوا في مبانٍ اسمنتية.
لا أنكر أن عملية الترميم والحفاظ
على الموروث الثقافي تكلف أكثر
من عملية البناء الحديث،
بالتقنيات والأساليب المتوفرة الآن,
لكن لماذا؟
تقع علينا جميعاً
مسؤولية إدراك أهمية هذه المباني،
ونشر الوعي للحفاظ عليها.
والأسوأ حتى، هو أننا بدأنا نتبنى مبدأ
هدم المباني القديمة،
حتى نبني بناءً سكنياً جديداً في مكانه.
حتى نفيد ونستفيد.
إنني من قريةٍ تسمى قرية “بيت فوريق”،
تقع شمال غرب مدينة “القدس”
وتتميز بموروثها الطبيعي والزراعي،
أكثر من موروثها المعماري.
وكما الحال في أية قرية فلسطينية،
لديها مركز تاريخي.
وهناك جامع، يجتمع فيه أهل القرية.
وفي يومٍ من الأيام قرر أهل القرية
أنهم بحاجةٍ إلى مساحة تستوعب الزائرين،
في المناسبات السعيدة والحزينة.
وقرروا بأن يضحوا
- كما ضحى سيدنا ابراهيم بإبنه -
بإزالة هذا المبنى القديم.
الذي يبلغ من العمر مئتي أو ثلاثمئة عام.
ونبني مكانه قاعة
لتستوعب هذه الأعداد الكبيرة.
لم تكن المشكلة هنا،
المصيبة هي أن حجارة هذا المبنى،
تم تسريبها وبيعها لجهات تابعة للإحتلال.
التي بالمقابل تقدر قيمة هذه الحجارة.
يقوم الإحتلال ببناء مبنىً جديد،
وتلبيسه بهذه الحجارة الأثرية
فيأتي الناس ويذهلون من هذا المبنى.
أود أن أشارككم بعدة ثقافات
متأصلةٍ في تاريخنا،
كما ترون في هذه الصورة.
ولو أنها غير واضحةٍ تماماً.
لكنها تعكس ثقافة التعاون.
التي هي إحدى الثقافات المتأصلة فينا.
حين كان يتعاون جميع سكان البلد
من رجال ونساء وأطفال
والشيوخ حتى في عملية البناء.
بمنهجية متناسقة وعظيمة للغاية.
مما يجعلني أفكر في واقع مجتمعنا اليوم.
أود أن أذكر ثقافةً أخرى :
أترون هذا المبنى الحجري؟
هل لدى أحدكم أي فكرة عن هذا المبنى؟
تسمى المباني التي من هذا النوع باللتون.
والتي توجد في معظم قرانا التاريخية.
وهو مبنى حجري يشبه المناظير
أو القصور الزراعية
عندما كان أهل البلد يجمعون الحجارة الجيرية
التي تتوفر في بلادنا بكثرة،
ويقومون بإحراقها فيه لمدة أيام.
وبعد إحراقها تتحول الحجارة
إلى مادة مسحوقة ناعمة
ثم يضيفون عليها الماء والتبن والصلصال
وغيرها من المواد
حتى تتحول إلى مادة لاصقة تستخدم في البناء.
ومعظم المباني القديمة والتاريخية كان
أساسها هذه المادة.
على عكس المواد الحديثة
لا يمكننا طبعاً عدم ذكر الإبداعات
والجهود الرائعة في هذا المجال.
هناك مؤسسات - للأسف - غير حكومية أو رسمية
تقوم بعمل رائع.
ومن الأمثلة التي أحب أن أذكرها،
المثال التالي :
قرية “نصف جبيل” القريبة من قرية “سبسطية“،
كانت تحوي على مبنيين قديمين،
تم تحويل أحدهما إلى بيت للضيافة ،
لاستقبال السياح الداخليين والخارجيين.
وتم تحويل المبنى الثاني إلى معمل سيراميك،
ويقوم بتشغيل نساء وفتيات البلد
اللاتي يصنعن منتجاتٍ فنية .
أرى أن هذا المثال عظيم.
لأنه جعل السكان يشعرون بقيمة هذه المباني،
وزاد من قدراتهم اقتصاديا وفنياً.
وبهذا قام أهل البلد بإظهار أنه
بالإمكان إعادة إحياء المباني
بطريقة تندمج مع الحياة المعاصرة .
وحافظوا على مبانيهم.
وكما ترون في هذه الصورة،
لا زال المكان يحمل تاريخنا. كأي مكانٍ آخر.
سنحت لي فرصةٌ من أربع سنوات،
بأن أكون جزءاً من فريق من
المهندسين  المعماريين
المهتمين بالحفاظ على
المباني القديمة وإدارتها.
وبدأنا برحلة التوثيق المعماري الرقمي
للمباني القديمة والأثرية.
واستطعنا توثيق أكثر من أربعين
موقعاً تاريخيا وأثرياً ودينياً.
باستخدام تقنية تعتمد بشكلأ أساسي
على المسح الضوئي.
التي تقوم بتشكيل مجسم ثلاثي الأبعاد
للبيئة المحيطة بجهاز المسح،
ونستطيع عندها باستخدام هذا المجسم
استخراج تفاصيل ومعلومات هندسية،
تساعد المرممين والمهتمين في هذا المجال
في عملية التخطيط والتصميم
للترميمات والمواد والتفاصيل
التي يحتاجونها لترميم لموقع الأثري
بما يتناسب مع المواد الأصلية الموجودة فيه.
يحمل كل حجر في بلادنا قصة ،
وتقتضي مسؤوليتنا أن نفهم
ما نملك بين أيدينا .
حتى نستطيع
أن نورث إرث هذه المعرفة للأجيال بعدنا
حتى لا يكرهونا، وحتى يظلوا فخورين به.
حتى نتذكر أننا كعرب، كنا وما زلنا وسنبقى
بإيماننا وإدراكنا
وعملنا الصادق على أرض الواقع،
وبإمكانيات بسيطة
ومصادر متوفرة بغزارة في بلادنا.
كنت أفكر في إحدى الأمور
التي تثير فضولي بشدة:
كيف استطاعت هذه المباني القديمة
وهذا الموروث الثقافي
أن يصمد كل هذه السنين ؟ بالمقابل نرى أنه
مع الإمكانيات والتكنولوجيا الموجودة عندنا
يبلغ عمر مبانينا الاسمنتية الافتراضي
سبعين إلى مئة سنةٍ فقط.
فبالتالي بإمكاننا، وسنكون.
تقدم لنا هذه التقنية فرصاً غير محدودة.
التي ممكن تطويرها لخلق عالم افتراضي .
باستخدام هذه التكنولوجيا لأهداف تعليمية
تعريفية وتوعوية للأطفال في المدارس.
أو حتى تركيز اهتمامنا في الجامعات
لخلق مقررات تهتم بهذا المجال.
وكما هو عنوان حدثنا اليوم :
“إن لم نكن نحن فمن؟”
وإن لم نغير بيدينا وعقولنا
وإبداعنا ومصادرنا،
فكيف سنتغير؟
وإن لم نقم بالتغيير من أجلنا وأجل أولادنا
وأجدادنا، فلمن نتغير إذاً؟
وإن لم نتغير الآن، فمتى سنتغير؟
[تصفيق الجمهور]
شكراً.
[إن لم نكن نحن فمن؟]